Wednesday edition of PFT ot PFT p.m. PFT
whatever Chris we haven't done this in a
while we haven't done this with you at
home that I can recall but hell I can't
recall anything over the past couple of
weeks we had our first day of TV only no
radio breaks to worry about we had a lot
more time to talk the show actually felt
like it moved faster there's less stress
because I'm not constantly worried about
the clock the clock the clock and we
have a break right at this break when we
got back and we're on radio break and
we're back for a TV segment we got to go
to break there we got this break and it
was nice I enjoyed it but we had some
things we didn't get to because there
were so many real NFL news items and one
thing Chris I want to start with I
noticed this from USA Today recent story
delving into the coaching career of
Steve Belichick the 32 year old son of
Patriots coach Bill Belichick and uh it
raises a bunch of issues for me and and
it all comes back to the concept of
nepotism in coaching and a lot of people
don't like the idea that coaches hire
their kids they think there's something
wrong with coaches hiring their kids as
a general proposition do you have an
issue with coaches exercising their
prerogative as they fill out a staff to
give a job to one of their kids or as a
favor to a buddy who coaches another
team that guy's kids I I don't it's a
tough subject now do I think it affects
you know the fact of the fact of maybe
lack of minority head coaches and things
like that yeah I do because of course
you're having family members take jobs
that are available but you know it is
for the most part you know the family
business for a lot of these coaches and
their and their sons if they do have an
interest in football so where this is
all day you know eat you know just think
about eat live breathe every day is
football football football and we see it
in a lot of other walks of life whether
a guy was hey this guy's successful on
Wall Street oh his dad worked on Wall
Street or this guy's a good doctor oh
his dad was a doctor I mean that happens
in everyday life I have more issues with
Oh
why are you know I saw this when I was
in the NFL you know hey how did you get
this job in the front office oh my dad's
the owners lawyer or my dad's the
owner's doctor I have more issues with
those people than I do family members
family members I can understand I really
can and I do think there is some value
to it nonetheless and you know yeah as
much as it can be unsettling that way
you know I don't know if I have a big
problem with it I think it happens for
three reasons first because so many of
these teams are family-owned businesses
where there's grooming of the next
generation to eventually take over and
involvement by the next generation and
other relatives Peter would feel
hypocritical for the owners to say the
coaches can't hire their kids to write
don't do is we do do as we say that just
isn't gonna fly and and it's easier to
justify when ownership is rife with
nepotism secondly for a lot of these
coaches they're making up for all those
Lost years where dad was always at work
dad couldn't come to the game dad
couldn't come to the recital where is
dead that's dad I haven't seen dad in
months now all of a sudden you're with
dad all the time I think that's a big
factor you're making up for the whole
cat's in the cradle phenomenal and it
plays out for coaches all over the green
and then finally and look and I thought
of this when I read some comments from
your buddy Kyle Shanahan
I think Super Bowl week when you have
been a coach's kid you bring to the
table a valuable set and experience
you're not freaked out by it you've been
around in your whole life there's
nothing about it that's too big for you
it's the Patrick mahomes dynamic why is
he so calm cool and collected he's he's
been in clubhouses major league baseball
his whole life it's not too big for him
I think that is a huge value that takes
it apart from nepotism I mean look you
just happen to be in the right place at
the right time you had the right dad you
were able to come to the office a couple
of days a week and get yourself to the
point where none of this stuff freaks
you out yeah well I think I mean you're
right I agree with you on all your
points and I think that's what people
lose you know you know lose sight of the
the facts of the matter here you know
these are not like coaches sons where
you just go and like oh
he's never paid attention to football in
his life and we're gonna bring him on
that we're gonna bring him on the you
know on the coaching staff and let him
have a say now even though he has no
clue what's going on know what you know
almost always these guys are highly
qualified individuals because of what I
said earlier it's what they grew up
around it's their their experience
they've been around that way of life
they're nuanced and you know some of
these tiny details that we wouldn't even
think about as outsiders and what it
takes to run an organization and being
head coach that way you know hey Sean
McVeigh is he pretty good oh well he had
a connection I know wasn't his father
but his grandfather got him in the NFL
right oh he was worth he's worth it he's
obviously hey how about Jim fossil son
oh he's only been like the best special
teams coach in football for a long time
running here so you know Kyle Shanahan
the exact same thing so yes these are
smart people who grew up around it know
every little detail about coaching and
what it takes and how to communicate so
they're very qualified I have like I
said much I don't really have an issue
with that part of it I am more of an
issue of like I said the guy who's got
no clue he's never been involved in
football or any shape of life but his
dad knows the owner and a my son wants
to work in football oh okay here's a job
have you any background no I just want
to do it oh okay
that to me is what bothers me more than
anything in football that takes jobs
away from the guys that are qualified to
get it so you know I'm all for it it's
the family business for a lot of these
people and and I think that it makes it
even more incumbent on the person who
gets the job due to a family
relationship or some other connection
where somebody knows somebody you got to
come in and bust your ass it's gonna be
glaring exactly or somebody who got it
in the in the unconventional manner
based upon who they know not what they
know you got to come in and show what
you know and what you can do are you're
not gonna be there for very long and
when you are there you're gonna be the
one that everybody else resents and and
doesn't fit because yeah we know we know
why Steve's here Steve's here cuz dad's
the head coach but Steve doesn't know a
damn thing of what he's doing now as a
relates to Steve Belichick and
the article that we wrote about it and I
encourage you to read our article and
read the original article USA Today
he clearly has the chops he clearly is
on the fast track
he clearly has the DNA and the work
ethic and everything to be another Bill
Belichick and before too long bill will
be retired and Steve will be the one
competing for Super Bowl championships
Chris yeah that's a very real
possibility I mean you know hey listen I
was around Stephen a little bit he's
smart he's a really hard worker and I
think he's trying to you know stay in
his father's shadow you know not not to
be a kiss-ass or anything like that but
he truly wants to learn every little
thing that his dad is thinking about
during a week or before a game I
remember us being on the super but on
the field in Super Bowl in Minnesota
with the Eagles and and New England
Patriots Brett Belichick walks out on
the field you know as the players are
just getting out there and he he has his
little you know checkpoints he checks
the field he walks around he looks at
the different things bill you know
Stephen Belichick was right there next
to him every step of the way so he can
understand what dad's process is so I
get it the big question is you know is
he gonna take over in New England does
he need to go somewhere else like a Kyle
Shanahan went somewhere else and proved
himself as one of the best offensive
coordinators at football with the
Houston Texans then he went and worked
for his dad with the Washington Redskins
this one's a little different and you
know I guess in my heart of hearts I
almost want to say I wish Stephen
Belichick would go somewhere else at
some point to just show everybody his
Worth and how good he really is or he
just hangs around until Bill retired a
big so over I mean this was the first
year I started to get a sense that maybe
Steve's the one who takes over for Bill
not josh mcdaniels did you get that
sense this year I I definitely I feel
like that's why josh mcdaniels got into
the coaching head coach coaching
conversation that maybe he saw a little
bit of the writing on the wall there
that ooh
Steve Belichick is rising up the ranks
and I might you know be the one left
without a seat here added to the fact
that you know I think there's a number
of people in football that look at it
right now and think that Belichick kind
of screwed over Josh McDaniels and the
searching hirings this year anyways
making him stay in the building didn't
let him go down the Caroline and
interview right
you know never got a chance to interview
with the New York Giants so you know
those are things I look at too and go
man how could Josh be real happy with
Bill Belichick at this point right now
and I think that would even favor
Stephen Belichick even more yeah they
get through the father-son thing for as
long as Bill wants to coach and then
when bills done coaching Steve takes
over the other curveball here though
there are some people who think that
Bill Belichick will end his career as an
executive a Bill Parcells type not that
that ever works it didn't work for Tom
Coughlin it really didn't work for Bill
Parcells but there's a there's a thought
that that bill gets a little slice of
equity and is like the VP of football
operations for another team if that
would ever happen with the team other
than the Patriots I could see him
wanting to hire Steve and that would be
so yeah if it would play out that way
yeah sure yeah I get that I don't see
Bill Dylan that though I don't I think
bill is he would be frustrated just
being the GM EVIC why are you coaching
him to do this why aren't you doing that
and I just think he's got to be in total
control and when he feels like he can't
do that he'll retire but if his son was
the head coach that could be different
you're right it would be easier to sell
that right no doubt no doubt
but bull will say look there's no reason
for him to stop he's one he's the
greatest of all time and you know he had
at one point said he can't see himself
coaching when he's 70 it's easy to say
that when you're not 70 now that he's
staring 70 in the face I think he's
gonna keep coaching for a while alright
we got a few questions answered before
we wrap this up today we're gonna try to
use this space to answer some of your
questions have a little more interaction
at max Hillier - what part of the Browns
organization is holding them back from
winning Chris well I think I'm gonna
look at ownership at first and then you
know I'm gonna look at the front office
to go along with that and just you know
again I'm yeah they're all into
analytics and you can't get a job on the
coaching staff and the GM apparently if
you're not into analytics - you know but
they've been analyzing and doing
analytics for four years now and the
team still been pretty crappy so at what
point did they get held responsible
there I feel like it was a normal GM or
a coach you know their their heads would
have been chopped off already you're
fired but for some reason Paul DePodesta
gets to run the team from you know
halfway across the country and never
seems to be accountable for anything
within their football team so yeah I
just look at it right now and I'm
looking at that and it seems like that's
why Stefanski got the job it seems why
the GM got the job they're all willing
to embrace the analytics which is fine
to a degree analytics don't tell the
whole story analytics last year said
will Grier should be the second
quarterback at drafted in the in the NFL
that was wrong the analytics were wrong
sorry so you know yeah I just I look at
that as being the number one issue the
thing that I found encouraging it seems
like the Browns are finally on the same
page Jimmy has it does seemingly has
preferred to have essentially people
pitted against each other and a bunch of
different viewpoints and and the result
is somebody wins somebody loses somebody
gets fired now Paul DePodesta the chief
strategy officer he's got the GME wanted
he's got the coach he wanted and now
let's see if this works and if it
doesn't work get rid of all of them
start over again but this idea of having
an analytics guy and a football guy and
expecting them to work together that's
just not gonna well so you know go
all-in go all-in and see how it plays
out and I think that I think ownership
has just been there's a line there and
the ownership has been too far on the
line of making too many changes getting
too involved
not trusting people they've hired to go
about their jobs and do their jobs all
right next one Oh Zilla qua should the
Giants go Isiah Simmons or tackle with
the fourth pick in the draft
yeah the Giants er they're an
interesting team I mean you know I would
also look at them as you know they could
possibly trade down to if they wanted
you know so so there's a lot of things I
think if you just look if I just looked
at it at number four right now oh that's
a tough one I really like Isaiah Simmons
I'm not sure exactly what position he is
and I haven't deep dive damn yet he's a
stand-up linebacker who was a one of the
freakiest athletes in the draft now he
lacks a little physicality to me a
little bit at the linebacker position
which is concerning to me so I think all
in all I would probably if you just
maybe pin down what they should do at
number four
I would probably go with the offensive
tackle it's a pretty impressive group
you can find a guy that can be your
starting left tackle for 10 years yeah
and the other thing too depending upon
how the quarterbacks come off the board
you have an opportunity to trade down
and get a lot more lottery tickets to
because the Giants have more needs than
just one player so if there isn't a guy
there that you think is gonna be a
transcendent talent that is clearly
better than the rest then
dangle it for a quarterback because
obviously you're not gonna take one and
get more picks and get more good players
who can become potentially significant
contributors yeah team moving forward
that's the big thing
Mike to Mike and just one more thing to
but the big question there will be do
they look at Isaiah Simmons as that type
of guy cuz he's a transcendent athlete
but a little bit of Mike like that
minkum Fitzpatrick remember when he was
coming out of college where it's like
what position is he is he a safety a
strong safety and nickel a corner what
is he I think there's some of those
questions with Isaiah Simmons too freaky
athlete very special I just I think that
some of the questions about what
position he truly belongs that could end
up hurting him a little bit and I'm with
you with the Giants thing I think
there's a good chance they could trade
down and and get somebody they want
maybe in the you know the 12 13 14 spot
wherever it may be
Dave Lowe 78 says he's a lifelong
Dolphins fan he's greatly concerned
about the increased risk / reward factor
of two otago below and due to his injury
history does the risk with to uh put
Justin Herbert on a more level ground
with tua in our opinion as it relates to
the Dolphins and it looked Chris I
remember last year with Colin Murray
saying the Cardinals have to take him
because it's better to guess wrong on a
potential franchise quarterback by
taking him and having him not work out
than to guess wrong by not taking him
and having them become that superstar
player somewhere else with tua I'm a
little more torn in that regard but if
you're looking for your next Dan Marino
and it's been over 20 years since you've
had a Dan Marino you know - uh does he
have more of an up side than Justin
Herbert if he's healthy and everything
checks out where where do you say I know
you've got Herbert ranked higher than
tua
but high-end potential who's got more of
it there it's it's Herbert there's no
doubt Herbert could be special
I mean Herbert
do things that you know again I'll say
this you know you put Herbert on Alabama
it's not fair it's not gonna be fair
he's a better athlete he's bigger he's a
stronger arm he's just about every bit
as accurate okay you know so honestly
Mike you know and again I like to Allah
in his game I too it is not a top-10
draftable quarterback to me
we even without the injuries I would not
draft to in the top ten I don't think
he's in a special elite player at the
position I think everybody's being
fooled by the Machine of Alabama and
going giving one guy the credit and I
just go you know I'm sorry I'm not gonna
give the quarterback credit for throwing
a four yard slant and then Henry rug's
running 70 yards for a touchdown I'm not
gonna go oh my gosh where did they get
this quarterback holy cow he's doing
things I've never seen before let alone
the injury history plays small those are
really concerning I think it would be a
huge mistake for the Dolphins to take to
it number five I think there's only two
top-ten quarterbacks in this draft for
me and that's burrow and herbart and
then there's you know Jordan love and
tua which I look at is you know back
half of the first round type draft picks
so your answer to Dave Lowe is forget
about to a take Herbert if Herbert's
there without question take without Ron
question without question
take Herbert and run Herbert has special
game-changing qualities and you know to
me there's there's a lot of risk with -
I just III don't see it I'm sorry
all right let's wrap up where we started
today at blue Road Earth wants to know
do you know if contingency plans being
made by the NFL to play in the fall I
can't see how it can be business even
close to as usual five months from now
we talked about this when we went on the
air at 7:00 a.m. Eastern Chris the
nonchalance that I detected from Jeff
past the NFL's general counsel saying
our plan is to go forward with a full
season full stadiums 16 games start on
time I I just hope that is some kind of
strange bravado and that behind that
they really are churning and working and
and and generating ideas
for how to get the most out of a bad
situation if we do get to the point
where this corona virus pandemic
requires the NFL to truncate the season
I just think it is way too optimistic at
this point to plan for a full football
season yeah I'm with you Mike and I
don't hear any rumors of any contingency
plans and that's the thing I brought up
during the show that scares me a little
bit you know there's just no talk of
that we're hearing rumors about you know
major league baseball NBA basketball
hockey trying to figure out ways to
finish their season and make things
right that way we haven't heard one
inkling and I've talked to a lot of
coaches while I'm sitting my butt here
at home during this this lockdown and
I'm just telling you none of them have
heard anything either and they're very
skeptical that this season will be
normal I think most coaches look at it
right now and just go there's no way how
how can we play a full slate of you know
full slate of scheduled games and
everything like that
it doesn't look good right now yeah I
think that I would prefer the NFL to say
we're planning not just for a season
we're planning for everything and we'll
be ready for whatever the public health
situation dictates at the time we're
optimistic that we will be in a spot
where we can play in full stadiums by
then but if we can't we will have a plan
I think that's what's more comforting to
people not this kind of stubborn we
intend to go forward because people
gonna look at that and say are you not
paying attention to what's happening in
the world and I think the more
comforting thing is don't worry we will
have a plan no matter what happens we
will have a plan we're identifying all
of our options and we will bring you
football in 2020 I think that would go a
lot farther to make people think the NFL
number one gets it and number two really
is connected to reality when it comes to
coming up with a plan for 2020 yeah well
I you know it bothers me and that's
where you know I get into the
conversation again where you know the
Commissioner for our sport works for the
32 owners and he's not necessarily
always seem to be worried about
everybody else it's more about
just pleasing that you know and I look
at ya my neighbor who lives down the
street here Adam silver you know I just
think he's shown great leadership
throughout this you know let alone just
easing the public easing the players of
his League
there's constant conversation and rumors
about alternate plans that what they
might do and I think as an NFL football
fan and the guy who loves the NFL and I
got great respect for Roger Goodell I
just don't hear enough of that and that
bothers me a little bit well and just
think of it this way and I'm not trying
to make it political look how long it
took the experts who are providing
advice to the President to finally break
down that wall to get him to understand
this is serious in all accounts coming
out of yesterday's briefing from the
White House is that the the president
was as concerned and as as pessimistic
as he's ever been finally because they
they put the paperwork on his desk that
got his attention about how serious is
gonna be and and I think maybe in time
assuming that there are experts around
the Commissioner they can get the
Commissioner to understand that this
this you know that group dynamic of
everything is gonna be fine if you have
enough people in the room saying
everything is gonna be fine they're all
gonna believe everything is gonna be
fine even if it's not that's my concern
that it's just this echo chamber where
they've got themselves convinced it's
gonna be fine and then it's someday
they're gonna open the door and they're
gonna say holy crap it's not fine that
and then they're not gonna have enough
time to come up with a good plan that's
what I'm saying now take it seriously
and come up with the plans because if
you wait until after the draft if you
wait until June or July be too late not
be in a position to come up with the
best plan and you're gonna have to have
to pull the plug on the season all right
let's pull the plug show you got
anything else one add no I think you'll
be hit at all you the man
all right great day today thanks
everybody for checking us out tomorrow
back on pft live 7:00 a.m. to 9:00 a.m.
Eastern have a great Wednesday we'll see
you Thursday
you